hello and welcome to sw19 for a special
edition of fwice coming up strawberries
and tweets how tech is changing tennis
glass cancer the UK will Brits embrace
Google's latest gadget domo arigato mr
roboto meet japan's android news anchors
and monsters aliens model and more
sci-fi and fantasy ruler games review
from fred perry to andy murray
technology has changed in tennis a lot
over the past 80 years huge developments
have been made in equipment clothing
broadcasting audience interaction and of
course line decisions but one of these
changes mean for the players and the
fans skies katie Spencer has been
finding out steeped in tradition
Wimbledon is perhaps not the place you'd
automatically associate with being ahead
of its time but while it may be the
oldest tennis tournament in the world a
great deal of work goes into ensuring
the competition is at the cutting edge
of technology today calling a serve is a
much easier decision thanks to net cord
sensors which pick up the tiniest of
vibrations Hawkeye is also standard when
Woden was the first Grand Slam to use
the electronic line calling system
across four courts the umpires and
Hawkeyes a team together to make the
best get the best resource for the
players it makes a lot more favor for
them gives them a second chance on the
title that they think is right but you
don't have to have tickets to center
court feel apart of the action this
year's competition is one of the most
social media-savvy experiences that when
wouldn't ever had starting with selfies
a daily Twitter picture competition is
just one part of a push this year to go
all out on user-generated content during
last year's two big competitions 6.6
million wimbledon related tweets were
sent this year whether you're looking
down from murray mount or watching with
your feet up at home a special social
command center will be crunching through
the data to work out what everyone's
talking about and there's plenty to be
tweeting
online Wimbledon slam tracker technology
has analyzed over eight years worth of
historical Grand Slam data from serve
speeds to previous clashes it works out
what a player needs to do to get that
all-important win it does really help
the fans understand what's going on I
mean you see players hitting a 50-point
rally 50 shot rally and you know it
looks absolutely amazing but knowing the
effort that's gone into that and getting
greater insights into the match helps
Wimbledon be at the forefront of tennis
around the world but for fans that have
camped through the night to get
courtside just how important is it to
share the experience we have to show it
off and tell everybody what we're doing
and you know make them jealous that we
get to do something that's cool while
we're here and if you're constantly
looking at your phone on your laptop
you're not always watching the action
people are missing the tennis now
because they're on their phones check-in
you know what's going on in the in the
fake world we might not be able to
control who comes away this year's big
Wimbledon winner but organizers are
determined to serve up a social media
experience that's faultless Katie
Spencer Sky News well now i'm joined by
richard newman who sports reporter for
Sky News Radio Richard we saw in Katie's
piece there a lot about the changes in
technology and you've seen a lot of
changes yourself covering the tournament
has it made the spore better for you
absolutely it's better for fans and four
players hawkeyes the biggest thing it's
been around about eight years now the
fans and the players can get involved
with each other when they watch it on
the screen those dodgy line calls can be
wiped out and they just move on from it
that's the biggest thing that we've had
in tennis over the last year's the
starts have changed to in the roof of
course yes in terms of stats no longer
just about acs and unforced errors it's
a whole wealth of knowledge for anoraks
and normal tennis fans just he gets
involved as well and the roof here at
Wimbledon ops ii got one on center
there's going to be one of number one
court as well it does change things for
players it's tends to slow things down
it's generally seen that when Roger
Federer would be Andy Murray in 2012 it
did play into the hands of Federer and
it's good for the organizers and for the
fans because when the rain comes they
get to complete the matches well there
is an argument isn't there that you know
sport is all about player talent you
know we are we losing some of that
now I don't think so because the balance
is right in tennis at the moment a
player only gets three challenges / set
plus an extra one in the tiebreak if
they win a challenge they keep that
challenge and if they lose it then they
lose another challenge so they can't go
too far with it at the moment avid as
things stand at the moment the balance
is right and has a John McEnroe made
some controversial comments about this
issue yes he's his latest idea is to get
rid of umpires and lines judges for the
players to call their own scores to use
the challenges and that would probably
taking it too far I probably be
detrimental to the sport ok Richard
Newman from Sky News Radio thanks for
joining us you're watching swype coming
up robot anchorwoman is this the
newsreader of the future but us away
from the clinking of champagne glasses
here across town the focus is on a glass
of a whole different kind we've heard
plenty about google glass and now it's
arrived in the UK with the company
asking for testers to try it out but
will Britain embrace the technology
skies Joe tidy has been finding out by
now we're used to the slick promos of
google glass but this one is different
recognize the setting that's right
Google's futuristic specs have come to
the UK and as a suitably slick launch
event the company opened up shop to
britts like in the u.s. a limited number
of units are up for grabs as part of the
Explorer program it encourages people to
give Google feedback the glasses will
cost you a thousand pounds and they're
still being described as prototypes
consumers in the UK and inventors in the
UK
in the UK a very rich heritage of
embracing new technology and inventing
new technology and so I think part of
the spirit of that is that we see a lot
of early adopters people who want to
test new technology beyond the bleeding
edge use it and build for so the other
people who we were hoping or jump on
board ok glass record a video the
Explorer program has proved very
successful in the u.s. google won't say
how many people are wandering around
wearing their specs but some estimate
there could be as many as 300,000 here
in the UK they could take some getting
used to it to use the full functionality
of glass users are encouraged to do
things like this which might go down
well in say San Francisco how will it go
down in scunthorpe American artist
Gretchen andrew has been using glass for
a year on both sides of the Atlantic
there are more of them floating around
in San Francisco and the population is
having conversations about technology
all the time whereas here people might
have heard of it they are getting to
understand what it could be what it is
it there's a lot more confusion around
what it does and doesn't do Google is
acutely aware that people feeling
self-conscious when they wear the device
could hold the expansion back and that's
why they've released a large range of
different designs to try and turn this
technology device into a fashion item
there's talk of deals with big name
brands like Oakley's and raybans on the
horizon but it remains to be seen if
this will help enamor us Brits to the
technology then a couple of problems
with google glass in the UK number one
is the great British reserve with people
that don't talk pictures on the tune and
so the chances of my decease up and
saying ok glass take a photo and people
are going to get nervous about it but
like all of these things the idea of
seeing you know using your laptop five
years ago it would have been horrific
now it's commonplace so we'll get used
to it Google won't say how many units
are on offer and they're keeping
tight-lipped on how sales have gone so
far but it looks like we're going to
have to get used to the sight of their
high tech specs Joe tidy Sky News you're
watching swype coming up project
livewire we take a look at how
Davidson's electric bike but first if
you're a fan of blade runner or
Battlestar Galactica you'll be familiar
with stories of machines replacing
humans but what sounds far-fetched
appears to be getting ever closer if an
exhibition in Japan is anything to go by
Sky's Stuart Duggan explains inside
Tokyo Science Museum a staple of science
fiction has come alive uncannily
realistic from skin detail through two
tiny facial twitches three incredibly
lifelike androids have been giving
visitors an insider look at what the
future holds for robotics you are so
boring in general its form is very
human-like but it's expressions are very
stiff it's a bit scary scary she may be
but kodomo roid is an incredibly clever
piece of engineering one which could
easily put reporters like me out of a
job pre-programmed every morning to read
news headlines and weather reports
robots like these could eventually mean
we wake up to our own personalized and
command in the home
if that's not your cup of tea how about
an Android babysitter to tuck in the
kids at night Oh Tony Royd is remotely
controlled users speak and move through
the Android seeing through its eyes it
was a bit creepy but once you get used
to it it's quite interesting and it's
interesting when you think about how
those sort of things could one day
actually be your friend or used in
elderly care or a variety of fields
Japan has for quite some time been a
world leader when it comes to robotics
the country's Prime Minister has even
talked about staging a robot Olympics in
2020 when it hosts the actual games
given what scientists are already able
to achieve science fiction could be
moving from the cinema screen to real
life in the very near future Stewart
Duggan Sky News you're watching swype
coming up bridging the gap how a
microchip has helped a paralyzed man
regain movement but first if I say the
word motorbike you can probably almost
hear the deafening roar of an engine but
not so with this bike skies Chloe kolpin
has been taking a look at Harley
Davidsons project livewire
not quite the sound you'd expect from a
harley-davidson this is the company's
first electric motorcycle but live wire
is still a work in progress when you
look at it when you hear it it may seem
different but you'll also realize it's
quite similar in the sense that it has
emotion it has character it has attitude
and that's what Harley Davidsons always
been about and what will always be about
electric or otherwise and we're not
walking away from what we've been we're
just adding to it
harley-davidson is taking the bike to 30
cities across the u.s. this year and
Canada and Europe in 2015 at the moment
the test bike has a top speed of 92
miles per hour it takes three and a half
hours to recharge and on average will go
for more than 50 miles the company is
using the tour to find out if this
specification is what customers want
this can be a lot of things and that's
what we're going to learn this could be
someone's third motorcycle in their
garage this could be their first and
primary motorcycle it could be someone
who's never decided to have a motorcycle
before that now gets inspired by this we
don't know how much the new electric
bike will cost yet but as the tour
continues we'll see just how charged up
people get about a quiet eco-friendly
harley-davidson Khloe Colburn sky news
coming up the e 3 games to watch out for
but first here's a round-up a better
thing you might have missed over the
past few days details about the first
phone from Microsoft and Nokia have been
released the x2 is Microsoft's debut
Android handset and as a follow-up to
the original X the company bought
Nokia's mobile phone division for 4.4
billion pounds in April at Google's
annual Developers Conference the company
revealed more about its Android wear
operating system an ingenious bit of kit
which looks set to make us all fatter
how'd you fancy having the power to
order a pizza in less than 20 seconds
and then I can quickly swipe to see and
repeat my last order just one more tap
to pay and the pizzas on its way it
would seem size is starting to matter an
apple we've got used to seeing the 4
inch iphone 5 but leaked details from
suppliers in china appear to show plans
for two bigger devices the largest is a
five and a half inch phone so similar in
size to Samsung's Galaxy Note 3 what a
whopper a paralyzed man has been able to
move his fingers and hands using his
thoughts thanks to a microchip implanted
in his brain Ian Burkhart from Ohio has
been unable to move from the chest down
after a diving accident he's the first
person to use neuro bridge which
reconnects the brain directly to
muscles and finally I found the perfect
way to get to work talk about Star Wars
come to life this is the air effects
Hoverbike it can go at 45 miles per hour
and will cost around 50,000 pounds when
it comes on the market in 2017 but hey
that's plenty of time to save now if
tennis isn't really your thing and
you're finding the world cup a bit tame
cameron robinson from GameSpot has got a
few fantasies to get you excited so if
you played far cry 3 and you enjoyed the
kind of playground hug whatever you want
kill whatever you want take over the map
kind of game play then far cry 4 looks
like it's going to have this but just
more so it's not on a jungle island this
time ficar forest set like at the base
of the Himalayas the idea is that you
can as a player you can explore that
whole kind of world climb up the
mountains jump off the top wing suit
down into enemy fortress season kind of
take them over so it looks like a lot
more of the same really fun game played
but the difference is the whole thing is
now caught as well so you can you know
have fun in the world blowing stuff up
riding elephants and everything but with
a friend in terms of story though we've
got like another crazy bad guy last time
it was vast who is this kind of Billy
and this time it's just really
interesting guy called pagan Lynn and
he's like The Dictator story of the
whole country that you've smuggled
yourself into and he's like they're the
best friend you've got but he's also you
know he's trouble he knew his bad for
you so I was a really interesting kind
of dynamic there but looks like a lot
more fun just like far cry 3 lots of
blowing stuff up and elephants so here
should I stay or should I go so if
you're a fan of the original alien film
then alien isolation is definitely a
game you're going to want to look out
for previously alien games have been
kind of hit or miss the most recent
aliens game we had was colonial Marines
which was a bit of a flop but this one
is very much in the feel of the alien
film not aliens so the key thing is
there's one alien it's not a shooting
game it's survival horror it's all about
escaping and hiding from this alien and
working your way through the environment
so the story is you actually play as
Ellen Ripley's daughter and you can go
in search of your mother and after she
kind of disappears you find the flight
recorder from the stroller and you go
and you try and track them down and you
come across the alien and and everything
just fits in exactly with the film so
the sound effects are the same the
environments are the same all the
screens have that kind of VCR kind of
interference that you'd expect and it
just looks incredibly atmospheric so I'm
really excited for this one so if you've
been searching for a good Lord of the
Rings game I think we might finally have
it this time looks like we could have
something quite special on our hands
find an old leader make him a war chief
shadow of Mordor takes place after the
hobbit so sauron's can be defeated he's
returning to mortal you know the big
boss is coming home and this kind of
messes up the whole ecosystem there
because it's kind of been controlled by
the Knights of Gondor they've kind of
taken over Mordor and their guard in the
black gates but it's been a long time
since I've had any trouble so they kind
of relaxed that the game begins you are
actually one of these Rangers from
Gondor and the game begins but you're
getting slaughtered as Sauron returns
however you then revived by this other
enemy and you're turned into a wraith
and then it's your job to kind of exact
revenge on the people who killed you and
your family the reason why I liquor the
interesting is a combat is really really
slick looks a bit like Assassin's Creed
but also as you go around and taking out
these orc captions that are based around
the landscape they level up if they
manage to kill
or if you take out one another one will
rise to power so there's like constant
politics and once the enemies which
looks really interesting so every time
you play it's going to be slightly
different so everyone's hoping that the
evil will then will kind of be the
spiritual successor to the original
resident evil kinda games before it went
all actually with Reza diesel 500 people
six the idea is you are this detective
and you encounter this evil and all of
your kind of fellow cops are killed and
you wake up in this really strange
demonic world you got to try and get
your way out but it looks like it's
going to have that real thrilling
survival horror aesthetic all the way
through so another one to be excited
about well I'll save for this week don't
forget you can catch up with all the
breaking stories on Sky News for ipad
our smartphone app and sky news com I'll
see you next time bye bye